alors je suis très inquiète on est très
inquiet très angoissée parce que depuis
2 10 ans la justice me méprise et on a
pris confiance
en fait ce qu'on a demandé c'est la
requalification des un viol en réunion
du premier crime qui a été commis donc
qui concerne les trois premiers pompiers
et l'a10 la mise en examen des 17 autres
pompiers qui n'ont jamais été mis en
examen alors qu'ils ont tous à minima
reconnu des actes sexuels avec
pénétration sur julie alors qu'elle
était vulnérable et qu'elles avaient
entre 13 et 15 ans depuis dix ans qu'on
mène ce combat
effectivement si c'était actuellement
que julie avait déposé cette plainte
pour viols en réunion qui concerne 20
pompiers elle aurait été bien plus
entendu que ne l'étaient les victimes il
ya dix ans maintenant c'est vrai que
heureusement lalibela les personnes
libérées leurs paroles paroles je pense
que l'affairé julie a été peut-être
aussi pour quelque chose parce que ça
fait plusieurs années que je milite pour
que son affaire soit entendu reconnu et
que beaucoup de personnes me disent que
grâce à ça allait déposer plainte
en fait nous la faire de julie des
départs on a une enfant de la république
qui a été violée par un mythe que les
pompiers de paris c'est l'armée sont
démis et je pense que si dès le départ
j'avais été reconnu et bien c'était
l'essai
c'est un c'est un scandale d'état
voilà donc donc ça fait ça fait très
chaud au coeur et puis ça l'egypte
mise et puis et puis les femmes ne
supporte plus ne veulent plus qu'on
viole nos enfants nos soeurs nos mères
dans le silence le plus complet sans que
la france réagisse et punisse les
violeurs ce n'est plus possible
en france les mineurs ne sont pas
protégés il n'y a pas de lois de seuils
d'âge de non consentement on est un des
seuls pays d'europe voire du monde à
avoir ce problème donc maintenant il
faut que les il faut que la france
prenne ses responsabilités et accepte de
traiter tous ces scandales
ma fille a été violée par vingt pompiers
il faut que la france lui rendre justice
ils doivent répondre de leurs actes
devant la devant la justice
commencer à enfin introduire une série
d'âge un seuil d'âge c'est formidable
parler de présence et indécent c'est
inacceptable un enfant mais manque même
jusqu'à 15 ans voire 16 ans est
incapable de pouvoir consentir à un acte
sexuel avec un adulte un adulte à un
pouvoir sur un enfant ce n'est pas une
relation d'égalité
on doit laisser nos enfants découvrir
leur sexualité entre entre enfants en fa
mineur et les adultes n'ont pas à
toucher les enfants
donc cette série d'âge à présent je
trouve je sais même pas comment c'est
possible
doser le proposer au 21ème siècle
et en plus avec la sphère de julie qui
montre bien que 13 ans ses parents ma
fille se sont complètement pas justifiée
elle la justice la méprise 2
dix ans elle dit qu'elle n'a pas le
sentiment d'être traitée en victime mais
d'être capable c'est passent au peigne
fin dans tous les sens et mon passé
c'est d'agresseurs puisque il faut
rappeler que les dix-sept pompiers n'ont
jamais été mis en examen et donc aucune
entrée en aucune enquête n'a été faite à
leur encontre
ma fille est présent creuse et angoissé
par par la réponse de la cour de
cassation puisque si si le l'arrêt de la
cour de versailles n'est pas casser
complètement les trois ans des pompiers
seront simplement jugé pour atteintes
sexuelles ses 7 ans alors que viols en
réunion sur mineure d'autre part les
dix-sept pompiers ne seront pas mis en
examen et ne seront plus poursuivis par
la justice alors qu'ils ont commis des
crimes sur elle des crimes en réunion
alors qu'elle était vulnérable et ça
c'est impossible impardonnable et
comment va-t-elle se reconstruire comme
ça donc voilà on july elle attend
maintenant que son délit en france c'est
d'institutions me rende justice permet
lui permettent que ses agresseurs soient
entendus par la justice est jugé pour
les crimes qu'ils ont